once a parking lot this crematorium is
now the final destination for hundreds
of victims of covet 19.
50 of deaths are not registered by the
government as kovat19
our ngo goes to the homes of victims of
coven 19 who died in quarantine
and brings them here to be cremated the
government only counts covet 19 related
deaths of victims who die in a hospital
and all others are unaccounted for
while the pyres burn day and night help
from around the world is on the way
in new delhi ventilators and other
medical supplies arrive from abroad
elsewhere tanks full of oxygen rushed
through the night for patients in
desperate need
german chancellor angela merkel says
it's just the beginning
above all else we will see what we can
do to help india
we are now working at full speed to see
to what extent we can bring oxygen
producing plants there
all of europe is behind this i also
spoke about this with the portuguese
prime minister who now holds the
european council presidency
and we want to do everything we can to
help india
the united states has pledged to send
india some of its millions of unused
vaccine doses but it could take weeks
before they arrive
just to be clear we have right now we
have zero doses available of astrazeneca
we're talking about what the f the fda
needs to go through a review
right to ensure the safety and it's
meeting our own bar and our own
guidelines
for health workers in the country's
overwhelmed hospitals that help can't
come soon enough
what do i do what do i do there is no
physical space we put him on
whatever support we can they're trying
to organize a bed somewhere or another
i get maybe around 50 calls every day
somebody's asking for beds somebody's
asking for cylinder somebody asking for
drugs
we don't have anything available
and patients are dying
on the front lines against covet 19
doctors and patients are measuring time
and breaths
not days or weeks
well dr juggal kishore is secretary of
the delhi branch of the indian public
health association and vice president of
the indian association
of epidemiologists i asked him how
things have got so bad
actually the india is second largest
country
in the world as far as the population is
concerned and even if you say
uh you know 17.6 million
uh people have suffered from uh this
covad and we have only just 0.2 million
deaths and when we calculate in terms of
then it is not even
one percent of the cases are dying but
this
number is such a huge and big uh
that you know for any small country it
can be a
nightmare so uh when it comes to number
then i think the india is you know top
in the list
and very soon we are going to actually
we have already
uh has the highest record of the
everyday cases
0.3 million like in three or four days
we are have one million cases
so because of this you know we have
exhausted all our
resources so is it possible to bring
this crisis
back under control or do you just have
to wait
until this it takes its its course
uh according to our predictions uh it is
soon going to be under control because
large number of patients almost i think
70
to 75 percent of the you know total uh
you know population is going to be
suffering from
and they will be you know developing
towards the humanity
so uh in some states like the
maharashtra
and delhi uh we have reached to the
highest peak and now the
number of cases are start decreasing so
uh in some state where the wave was
started early we had uh you know
receding now
and in some state like the u.p and assam
and bihar we are seeing some uprising
but at the national level you know it is
now uh you know almost i think we are
reaching to the highest peak
all right thank you for joining us
doctor dr juggal kashuri
from the indian association of
epidemiologists
thank you